For what reason you used a miracle to set up a trap for 10th place.
Can't you talk about this because of restrictions
? How about this even if you dart? What is
10th place?
Even
better, I'm being deceived to the end. I'm chased and I'm sure I'm cooperating with the undesired guarantee of the liberation of the century.
Barus looks like he doesn't have a life.
[Music]
Apparently, he didn't improve his tea skills while he was away. He's
only good at making tea, but he's a cute little
girl, isn't he?  It's cute enough
I can't say that the world is dangerous anymore. Yes
,
it seems to you, but
if you don't know the cause, why did you give Barus a miracle
?  If that's the case
, it's a late town, but it
's a miracle, but I can't speak from my mouth. Don't
go through the poor. That's not the story
.
I'll be detained and
billed  It's awkward to guess Frederica can't break the restrictions on her own initiative, so I can't
help but force Barus
to make such an excuse
.